hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want oh
it's just like a month that's earth tech
dope don't look at you you look fine now
I know I feel way better I'm my house is
going crazy I I think a cat sat here
earlier make sense I've actually thought
I'm really allergic to cats so sometimes
when I hug you
sometimes when I hug Jill's mom like
after they leave but I don't know that
incident but after you guys leave I'm
like do you feel that when you come to
our place no cuz I pound the certain if
I come mmm my regular stuff yeah
what am I'm regular and I like to kiss
her mom or something I know I glop her a
little bit these little buckets then she
leaves or Mike with the fuzz one on my
mat on the [ __ ] cat on her I'm so
stupid
yeah you should I am still in denial
that I'm not that I'm allergic to cats
because I keep hoping that it disappears
but worse over the years dude coming
into my level cuz like with Julia -
Julia came over she had a circus she
saved my ass yeah one of the roommates
has a cat so I'm sitting there and I'm
petting the cat I'm having a good time
she goes Julia's like you know I think
she stopped paying the cats like - not
fine and my [ __ ] eyes like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] eyes and [ __ ] you know I
mean you can feel like the eyes getting
bigger [ __ ] I'm eating the [ __ ] eyes
and stuff the render snippy [ __ ] ice
there in ease yeah there's you know how
bellybuttons has any analysis there's
[ __ ] that have anything out of these -
what supports the Audi part
well the Audi's is like when a
roast-beef fan yeah there's like lips
but then the a knees are like just a
line you got a nice tight any [ __ ] you
got a line there bagina is like this and
some people their vagina is like out in
the open you know what what work that we
start talking about and JK news I
started using in our personal life
Boosie go see the back [ __ ] cause i
like senior busi stop saying everything
that [ __ ] happy
what the [ __ ] can we have some private
[ __ ] yes I'm trying to be romantic with
you but it is weird that I know what
your vagina looks like now how how do
you know he presented it in a very nice
package so I'm for that but if he was
like oh that shit's all there that'd be
like what if he was like you know roast
beef like yours babe like ah you never
seen that picture before and it's like I
lose like a chart that went around for a
while and it was like 20 different types
of vaginas yeah you seen that before
right you know what so it just feels
like cupcakes
my very first girlfriend had a very neat
vagina and because I'm so naive I assume
that every vagina was gonna look the
same
yeah you know so that's cuz that's my
first experience as a young 18 year old
boy and then afterward I'm like that
doesn't look the same as that doesn't
look and they're all like different
they're just yeah different but I think
like a me it's like when you open it
then it's the rose beef is inside but
it's inside so you gotta open it like
that to do these two until I saw that
graphical chart because like even in
porn there aren't they like all in ease
so I just know what your [ __ ] looks
like you open an oyster and it looks
exactly like a vagina vagina what does
an oyster look like take a photo I don't
know other ones are just like rare maybe
I don't know what about dick there are
so many different types of dicks and
they are so scary like there are so many
scary ones there's some look like that
blind hairless mole mole baby yeah I
think they got some they look like dick
so I'm gonna don't look like dick so you
know like that get me out Eilert what
the ones that the skin on the dick
doesn't match the skin on the body yes
that is that's a great thing that
salvation was my match yeah I just saw
the one I've seen it in porn where it's
like dark like it's darker than the skin
I'm like yeah I've seen it
um white guys and black guys like their
skin is white but then their dick tip is
red as hell or like that line there's
like a line that match that gets
gradient where they got circumcised like
a match yeah yeah and then lower like
it's 2-tone right it's like a lighter
skin like Oh like an end it gets it gets
like darker yeah I remember one time I
saw this reddit post and it was a guy he
was like I have two penises ask me
anything was it like can we see a
picture well I mean later on in the post
it was like edit edit since everyone's
asking here you go and I stood there for
five minutes and I was like do I want to
see this cuz this might buck me up for
the rest of my life
Wow did you want it like you got spoiled
I mean I did but it wasn't what I
thought it was it was like it was like
two mushrooms like just growing out in
the wild and one bigger than the other
that kind of yeah their nipple kind of
kind of if you wanted it to be like this
huh so you're like one in the ass one of
the [ __ ] well I don't know why but I
was picturing like you know that snake
head I know that demon like it's I think
it's like a Cerebus Cerebus or something
Cerberus Cerberus yeah the three-headed
dog that's what I was imagining just
alright like three of them just coming
at you you know that's I don't know why
I was thinking that oh like two digs
going this way yeah it's just coming at
you I was thinking two dates going this
way oh that came out this way it was
like wow wow yeah you ever saw
two-headed snake yeah they were out what
was the difference like a big brother
and a little brother I really remember
cuz I'm gonna be I'm gonna be honest I
remember the be any pain Olympics more
than I remember the two-headed penis
that [ __ ] me up
what does the BMA payment but David
coming up four years don't ever look it
up David let's talk about the internet
you've never seen that look at no no
what is that
you've never seen that before the PME
pain Olympics it was okay so BM e
Magazine was this like it was one of the
first internet emag designs and I used
to go in on it all the time because
people would upload pictures of
piercings you can see a bunch of
different types of tattoos
scarification different piercings seven
I was just really into like nose
piercings combinations of cool piercings
and this was when I god this hadn't have
been like in 2005 oh it was like
throwback throwback okay maybe 2005 2006
or so but there was a subsection where
it was more hardcore stuff like you know
like suspensions and just like painful
modifications this contest called the
pain Olympics for people to do the most
extreme painful disgusting things they
could and submit a video and the dude
that one cut his dick off what what's
the prize lip it just told like we have
a spot on the website and it was like a
60 second video with like metal music of
this dude just cutting his dick that's
what it's like a knife nope nope the one
that I saw oh my god yeah cuz I had to
turn it off immediately
I saw one where this dude he wrapped his
balls in the string and course there's
only guy just clicked off of this video
I know it has to be fake he tied his
nuts and 7/8 and it fell it was like
this like this kind of string right all
he was trying to cut it off yeah that's
what 11 so then it turned like a
different color of course but then he
ended up like beating it and it like it
like blow dust up and the insides were
like cream so I'm like this can't be
real like this dude these these my Oh
disturbing insides are green under the
skin yes that can't be real because he's
probably bursted blood vessels kind of
like a UH one thing that they told us in
my scuba diving class they're like when
if you ever get cut underwater and you
start bleeding on the blood comes out
blue green don't freak out it's because
it only turns red when it hits oxygen
yeah if you get bit by like a shark or a
[ __ ] get cut or something the Bloods
not gonna come out red it's gonna come
out but that's just probably because
they don't want to freak the audience
out but if you're on explain all that
you're underwater it's gonna come out
Bluegreen I'm mortified right now dude
but you know
yeah it doesn't seem that when you're 13
that was the first Nick I ever saw David
and it was gone just like that
the funny thing is is that it was a
whole campaign let me to people entered
videos and the title if you look up be
any pain Olympics they're looking on
video no no there is one is one dude
cutting off his dick well there's no
videos if she just said another one I
saw the ball one I don't think Oh every
year there's a different one
whoo that ball person must be so upset
it's like dude balls are way worse than
a dick and is he like arguing for a spot
like what the [ __ ] happens ha ha same
day I finally saw the two girls one cup
because I saw all back-to-back
this isn't 2010 right after it already
has on his height and I'm like I want to
see what everyone's talking about
and so and I saw that that when you
first got Internet she's like let me
binge on all this [ __ ] better who's been
talking about know those two things that
like perverse things like that either I
got curious to watch it I mean when I
was younger I did now I'm not about it
at all like I don't even I used to watch
a lot of like murder-mystery shows I
love true crime for like years and then
like in the past year I kind of had to
stop watching it cuz I've been going to
sleep with like one eye open like
holding a knife like this I got four
locks on my door I ain't playing around
y'all what did you stab yourself in your
sleep
even on this show called Spartacus they
slice the dick off and that [ __ ]
traumatize me on a TV show
sliced that's not like it came off clean
now like that it was like this warrior
or something that one of the [ __ ]
royalty people she was coveting him this
sounds like Game of Thrones which it
actually happened on Game of Thrones
David you should watch that shows and
they don't show you oh they showed this
Dickus lifestyle no I legit screamed cuz
I just it's just too personal
yeah it's real I realize no it wasn't
real but it was on the show I think I
had a huge dog and because that lady was
coveting him the [ __ ] husband chopped
off his day and I promise
I did not expect that [ __ ] my own had
the whole caught VHS collection of faces
of death oh my sister would watch that I
could never watch that it was like a
compilation of deaths and like people
capitated like no footage will cease
imagine like foot pops documentary but
like everybody dying I just remember
worst way possible like like weirdest
ways to die though it wasn't using the
video the guy getting sucked into a
airplane turbine oh my it was like on TV
TV yeah it was on Spike TV yeah but
there was somebody who got sucked into a
turbine to survive oh I think we talked
about it here you'd spit him out she was
hilarious
so here's close were all chopped up but
he was fine really
Oh funny because we knew he survived
yeah that flow just went cuz I would
never watch it like that on my own ever
I don't know that at all dude I feel
like when I was a kid I think that's why
I don't like it now because when I was
like 12 the morbid curiosity here I was
on August like gore calm like all that
[ __ ] going out car like when you guys
played that video earlier with a woman
got caught I couldn't even listen to her
scream because it bothered me to hear
her in pain you know be cute don't look
[ __ ] don't look at early because you
will turn into me and I'm a [ __ ] I'm a
[ __ ] now I've been a [ __ ] the whole
time dude I can watch it no I the born a
[ __ ] or not I'm trying to think like I
don't know why I was so young to like
what was the first website y'all went to
like when you like got online , a low
calm yeah that's Jeeves dude that's all
I did yeah I don't even remember
I've been hardened yeah well I wasn't
Avenue I think I was on messenger and
stuff I still feel bad
oh my ankle I can't fished a guy when I
was 10 and I still feel so bad about
that
like what did you at least give him some
good cyber oh my god it was ten Joe I
don't know because when I was a
what-do-you-call-it I was a reverse
molester
I was molesting people when I told her
that was older than me Melissa that was
molesting back I was having cyber sex
with older women disgusting how'd you
even know what's right I said you want a
cyber but then like how did you
to continue the conversation all I know
they could have been a fifty year old
man pretending to be a 24 year old woman
no but I'm saying cuz like I I would I
was in those situations - oh they asked
me that and I'd be like okay yeah sure
let's do it whatever and then they'll
all you really have to do is say oh yeah
and now you learn for the next time but
then like they would say things like Oh
tell me this or whatever and I'm like do
you like to suck dick or like some [ __ ]
like that
I'm sitting there with my friends
giggling do you like dick Oh
question mark I don't want children this
just brought me back to a childhood
trauma
okay somber one time I'm on AOL
messenger and there was this girl and
she and like she was really popular I
think I'm like fifth or sixth grade so
this was like that and so like she was
really popular and I wanted to be
popular and she would talk to me on AIM
and like one day she told me that she
would go into these chat rooms and like
cyber with these guys and she would
start just copy-paste in the
conversations and sending them to me and
like it would be excerpts and like I
didn't want to like be like I didn't
wanted to not like me so I just be like
cool and then like she would start
sending me more and I was like haha so
cool and then she like started sitting
like are you horny because I am check
this out it made me so uncomfortable
comfortable cuz I didn't know what they
were talking about Oh one day she sent
me a conversation like info and my
grandparents don't know like what a copy
and paste versus an actual conversation
looks like so they just saw this very
graphic conversation with all these
things and I hear in the other room both
little bows chat window code cuz I knew
her background color and I was saying oh
no I [ __ ] knew exactly what was up
and I couldn't explain myself out of it
there was no if ands or buts about it I
was lying and this was my conversation
oh my god my mom watches his mom it
wasn't me but yo it's not me oh my god
it was not me what I wonder if they know
now that is that is no of course not
[ __ ] they don't know what copy and paste
is but they I couldn't explain
oh people don't know technology either
because jess has a hotmail account and
her dad I bet you man eight roti speech
mal I was but the remember hotmail yeah
yeah even if it's not mail as an mal
it's like hot you know yeah when you
read all that was lining what is just
hotmail [ __ ] you should have been
doing this her dad oh when she was a kid
because she had a hotmail email account
you shouldn't be doing this like hotmail
of this is inappropriate all this she's
like no you don't understand it that's
not what it is what's this job who's
yeah nobody's yahoo and around here i
would post my fire party flyers on my
door in my closet door and then she
would she went up to one one day she
started reading it she was like what
does virgin location mean what does that
mean to me what does that mean I'm like
it just means location I hadn't had a
party there yet she's like [ __ ]
swinger party and a bunch of virgin
girls are gonna be there oh my god
funnier the [ __ ] that parents like the
disconnection that they had with our
generation it was so far I wonder if
that's gonna happen like now with us oh
yeah I mean it's so easy for us to just
go on urban dictionary or just read some
[ __ ] online and then understand it back
then it's like the culture was
completely off if you didn't know
younger people you didn't know their
world you didn't know what they were
doing it's totally different
I had another it kind of like your thing
I cut those 70 minutes yeah what yeah
more wonder continued I had one time
we're like okay there it was like a
trend I don't know if anyone else had
this we're like we would make our like
screaming if sometimes we would take
Lyra things from like song lyrics and
stuff I don't know it's so like I always
used to change my username like every
couple of months and a lot of times I
would look at lyrics and like think of a
thing well I love this band called orgy
and they had a song called stitches so I
made my username one time or GX stitches
he's like what [ __ ] is this I didn't
know what an orgy was I just thought the
word looked cool cuz like you know like
spelled out it kind of looks like a cool
word o-r-g wine yeah or DX ditches so I
casually make my new screen name and I'm
telling everyone hey guys new username
and my moms like no the [ __ ] it's not
gonna do a LimeWire and all those toys
oh yeah every time you download a [ __ ]
you would get [ __ ] porn spam yeah
yeah time but my parents didn't know
that [ __ ] and so like I they were gone
to my computer and all this [ __ ] dick
[ __ ] [ __ ] would pop up and I'm just
downloading post boys to men you would
it would take like [ __ ] the four hour
to download a song music I swear to God
but that you just had to take that
chance cuz you get viruses all the
[ __ ] time just suck and they didn't
understand they thought you were going
to porn sites yeah they're stupid I
watched porn on my friend's computer not
mine
weird while your friends there we would
always watch the buck in the photos that
it's so funny together yeah as a kid
as a kid you would always look at those
[ __ ] individual photos what extends
every load up you're alone on this one
dude yeah we would pass around floppy
disks really and it's like oh oh there's
a whole body alright cool
click the next picture and they tell you
like mental mental pictures later I
don't know sorry we're next like
Internet reminiscing here I still
remember like my mom having a
conversation with like another like some
one of my friend's parents because they
had found out like my friend's brother
they they saw like a 15 or so he was
watching hantai and they were so
concerned they were like stories are
great does this mean like what does this
mean he's watches are great he's looking
at anime titties
like would you be concerned as a parent
if you didn't understand Danny he's like
you don't even know what anime is and
your child's just watching him to see a
[ __ ] ogre [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of a
girl's face yeah if you don't
dad and he see like a tiger show up with
a human dick on it you're like yeah
people like an octopus [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of a lady and she likes it just
weird
[Music]